Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Subhan Allah. Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in the chapter of patience
from Riad Sal authored by the Neui the
25th narration the first narration
respective to the chapter
the narration of Malik
in which he states that the messenger of
Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
purification
is half of Eman and alhamdulillah fills
the scales and subhan Allah and
alhamdulillah
fill or occupy what is between or
everything between the heavens and the
earth. The next statement he makes is
and
prayer is light. Prayer is light.
When we
look back to the time of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
light
was something that
always came accompanied with heat.
In order to have light,
you need to have heat with it.
There were no fancy light bulbs that you
know give us so and so
amount of lumens with very low wattage
to make it bright without the heat. If a
person wanted light, they had to light a
fire
or there had to be some element of
danger incorporated with this light
which was a byproduct of fire.
And so when the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam tells us in this narration that
salah is light,
this is to say that prayer
is that byproduct of light
without the difficulties and dangers
that come with
fire.
Now why is this important? This is
important because as we're going to hear
there are other things which are named
as light.
So for instance in this same narration
he tells us
and patience
is also light. But he doesn't say n he
doesn't use that word.
He uses light for the prayer but he uses
the word for the patience.
In the Arabic language is light that is
accompanied with heat.
So he is telling us that prayer is light
and patience is also light but it comes
with great difficulty.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala described put
these two words together in the Quran.
He says subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
He says that he is the one who has made
the sun as a burning light
and made the moon to be pure light.
Light without the byproduct of heat and
difficulty and sweat and discomfort.
These two things are put together in the
verse the verse at the beginning of the
chapter in which Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says
and seek aid in patience and prayer.
So patience and prayer we mentioned what
is the significance of these two things
to be mentioned together
patience and prayer. Here we get another
aspect of that description that prayer
is light
and patience is difficult light. It's
also light
but it's difficulty. What comes with
patience? Wisdom. Wisdom is not
something be ha that can be had
overnight. Wisdom is a reflection of
experience
that has been understood properly. This
is what we call wisdom. Person has a
life. They've experienced many things
and the things that they've experienced
they have processed them or they have
understood these experiences
properly. And so now they have wisdom.
If they could go back, how would they
behave? These are the choices they would
make different because they've learned
lessons. This is what wisdom is.
The only shortcut to wisdom is the book
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Now you
can have a young man 15, 20 years old
who has understood the book of Allah
with the wisdom of the sages,
with the wisdom of prophethood in his
chest and is able to make wise decisions
because of what he has of the book of
Allah.
But that can only happen if a person
understands the book of Allah and if
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has graced this person to not only
recite the book of Allah but be led by
the book of Allah
we've mentioned this before people who
read the Quran there are two types of
people who read the Quran there are
those who read the Quran and there There
are those who lead the Quran.
Those who read the Quran
are those who will be guided by it. They
put the Quran in front of them. They
read it and they follow where the Quran
takes them in spite of themselves. Those
who lead the Quran are those who already
know
and the Quran is just there to back them
up and reaffirm everything that they've
already decided.
So they've already decided this is how
marriage should be. So when they read
the Quran all they see is what they've
already decided. How can this person
ever be guided by the Quran? They can't.
A person has already decided what
honesty is, what success is. Already
decided how the life of this world is
and the hereafter. Already decided this
is how Allah is.
So when he reads descriptions, names and
attributes of Allah, he will only see
what his heart and preconceived
notions allow him to see. and he will
then be blind to everything else.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam in
this narration tells us that prayer is
light. What happens in prayer? The
recitation of the Quran
and patience
is light but it comes with difficulty
and it comes with heat. It comes with
strain. It comes with sweat. It comes
with toil. patience will show you
eventually
but with great pain and difficulty.
So when you put these two things
together
when a person first arrives at a
junction they stop and they are patient.
What does that mean? They are patient.
They do what Allah has commanded in
spite of themselves.
But how long can they repress
their desires that are going against the
Quran and Sunnah? Not very long. They
will come out eventually. You have to
deal with them. Can't just push
everything down.
And so that is where the prayer comes
in. When a person prays and reads the
Quran and prays and reflects on the
Quran becomes more free of sin and then
understands of the Quran and the more
they understand of the Quran, the more
they pray and become free of sin. And
the more free of sin they become, the
more they read and understand the Quran.
Now the person
understands
and something deep and fundamental will
change in them. Now those repressed
emotions are no longer repressed rather
they are now redirected
and they are reaching equilibrium
with
the will of Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
Their will is slowly coming into line
with the will of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Now they are reaching
equilibrium to where they don't have to
strain to obey Allah. They wouldn't have
it any other way.
And this is true faith. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam for this reason
said
He said, "None of you will truly believe
until his desires are in line with what
I have brought of revelation." That's
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]